foreign
's flat five three back off a little bit
14 from six six
all right yeah we're not gonna make it
to cannonsville uh what did the are we
greenlit
I'm just gonna take a minute No One's
Gonna Get out of my way here
six seven six four six six
four six six
they're getting off at the 114.
okay sounds like they're getting off at
the 114 North at Cass County
[Music]
37 I'll roll North just in case
they hit my patrol car
foreign
[Music]
we're going the wrong way on northbound
for mission to pit
[Music]
speeds at 43 permission to pit
under the north mile speeds at 43.
requesting permission to pit
six six fourteen stop
we're coming up to the fire guys
[Music]
still southbound speeds of 45.
3 the 45 1359
five three from six six just follow her
I'll try and break
[Music]
she's still Southbound
6 4 14 I got one at West River heading
north
I think I'm gonna have to shut this
thing down here at 17 miles I can get
some help cutting across
we're gonna be southbound in the
southbound Lanes
five three move out of the way
[Music]
five three from six six back off slow
down traffic Foreman
[Music]
foreign
18 Mile Road here I think real quick
what's up
yeah real quick
oh you can monitor on the stalker I'll
call you
backsticks let him know
[Music]
he's got the three-way shut down at 12
miles
[Music]
get out of the car
get on the ground
you're back you're not you're not get up
enough hands behind your back now
everybody relax everybody hands behind
your back okay
okay bye
let's just stay there okay I know that I
know it's going to be warmed up
don't go grab enough
State Police make yourself known anybody
else in there
100 you were yeah 606466
foreign
like red shirt beard
at westbound Archer Road Westville Arch
Road
you bailed
negative
wrong way wrong way
100 blocks
back in the right lane of travel
[Music]
I'm celebration boy
um
rear vehicle
again
I'm sorry we're celebrating some coins
it's a short box truck
s
[Music]
together
Corey where are you at now
Archer 93 r393
[Music]
sounds
our house and Burger King he found
what I'm calling from ASF
ound
[Music]
s
for about 60 miles an hour
all right so unit is 2300 Archer
[Music]
found in the new Butler Plaza
Boulevard
[Music]
all right we're back on Archer Road I am
now the weed vehicle
oh
single four into a ASL canine until we
Mount pleased
hey you good
okay
[Music]
all right we are at 35th Boulevard to
eastbound wrong side of the road coming
up to 34th Street
[Music]
trying to get to it speed 60 mile an
hour
[Music]
foreign
Northbound 34th Street northbound 34th
Street
I'm calling it Northbound through Lake
Meadows Boulevard on 34th Street
[Music]
trying to get up to a pit
[Applause]
signal board and a long line of traffic
accidentally Rock School a lot of wrong
winter travel past Piccadilly continuing
on
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
okay
thank you
foreign
[Music]
okay
here's my location
[Music]
I know but
I don't need to know
hey beautiful
um
thank you
so be ready
foreign
[Music]
everybody
foreign
stop
and work this out
he's sitting right here
foreign
[Music]
okay
um
foreign
he stopped talking and he's moaning they
do not have any Rubble out of him now
here
thank you